Every movie fan knows that some of a film's
key scenes can wind up cut down, skipped over,
or removed from the finished movie completely.
Usually, that means some welcome moments are
missed, but other times, it creates plot holes
and obvious questions the movie never answers.
Either that, or the writers and directors
never cared to actually come up with an explanation
at all.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movie Plot Holes
That Can't Be Explained.
Star Trek
There actually IS an explanation for what
the movie's villain did for the twenty five
years between his arrival in the past - killing
Kirk's father - and kidnapping Spock.
Deleted scenes showed he and his crew were
locked up in a Klingon prison.
But there's no way to explain how, or why
Spock entered the wormhole with the enemy's
ship, but was spit out twenty five years after.
And the idea that a mining crew would be able
to predict where or when Spock's ship popped
out is practically impossible.
The Avengers
In the emotional climax of the Marvel team-up,
it's Tony Stark who sacrificed himself to
save New York, flying into a portal above
the city to destroy the alien invaders' ship.
The plan works, too: when the nuke detonates,
and the portal closes, the enemy forces drop
dead.
Wait, what?
Why would living, breathing soldiers die when
their command ship was destroyed?
Even director Joss Whedon has admitted that
there's no explanation, and that even though
he isn't proud of the conclusion, it worked
to end the fight fast.
The Hobbit
There are plenty of reasons why the giant
eagles of Middle-Earth didn't just fly Frodo
and the One Ring to Mt. Doom, but in the first
prequel, it's an even bigger problem.
After saving the dwarves, the eagles make
sure to drop them off miles from their goal
- guaranteeing a second movie, but making
no sense.
The explanation from the books isn't possible
here either: since these eagles can't speak,
they can't tell Gandalf that the favorite
they owe only gets the dwarves this far.
And the mountain they're headed for?
It's still 200 miles away.
Director Peter Jackson wanted to show it much
closer, creating one ridiculous ending, and
an insane plot hole.
eagles don't speak, mountain shouldn't be
visible
Iron Man 2
You gotta hand it to Whiplash, the villain
of Iron Man's second movie: he knows how to
make an entrance.
Disgusting himself as a pit crew member during
a race in the streets of Monte Carlo, he jumps
onto the track, unleashing his weapons on
Tony Stark when he's most vulnerable.
But there's a problem: Tony only decided to
race the Stark car minutes before the race,
which Whiplash couldn't have known.
That makes the stolen disguise and the rest
of his plan either insanely lucky, psychically
predicted, or just a plot hole they hoped
fans would overlook.
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
Believing that witches and wizards cast magical
spells and charms is easy enough, but control
over time and space is something completely
different.
Still, time travel was introduced in the third
movie, which let Harry and Hermione rescue
themselves.
Even if you accept that turning back time
was only allowed for taking multiple classes,
not undoing murders - which is hard to believe
- the characters had no reason to feel rushed
or panicked in the final act.
If they screwed up completely, why wouldn't
they just go back and try again, knowing they
already pulled it off?
Iron Man
Tony Stark might have used the magnet in his
chest to keep him alive AND power his Iron
Man armor, but things changed fast.
You would think that making the armor run
on his own arc reactor was a foolproof security
system: since only he could use them.
It's impossible enough that the suit can fit
perfectly around almost anyone, but why would
Tony leave them powered up, ready to be flown
away by anyone who came across them?
It's required for the plot and villains to
get the upper hand, but makes zero sense when
you think about it.
Anyone can use the armor?
A massive security problem?
Transformers
It isn't coincidence that brings massive alien
machines to Earth in Transformers, but the
AllSpark - the cube of energy that brings
each Transformer to life.
When the heroes take the cube on the run to
keep Megatron from building a new army from
Earth's machines, things go wrong, fast.
But the AllSpark just gives life - so is every
single machine born evil, immediately attacking
innocent people?
The only answer is that it's a chest by the
filmmakers - or all Transformers are Decepticons
at birth.
It's a shame, too.
Seeing Earth machines joining the up with
Optimus Prime would've been even cooler.
Fast & Furious 6
No fan can forget the massive action set piece
that closed out the movie, with the stars
fighting to keep the villain's plane from
taking off, fighting in, under and around
it.
But the thirteen minute sequence raises one
big question: How long is this runway?
Movie magic is one thing, but when people
actually sat down to do the math, they realized
the runway would need to be close to 30 miles
long for the scene to work as shown.
Even for this series, that's a stretch.
Back to the Future Part 3
The final chapter in the trilogy kicks off
when Doc Brown is sent back into 1885, frying
his time machine's circuits, and stranding
him without repairs or even gasoline to return
to the future.
When Marty travels back to rescue him, half
the problem is solved, but he has his own
gas lines sliced, stranding them both.
But it shouldn't have: Doc claims a gas station
is still decades away, but by 1885, California's
oil rush was well underway - producing a ton
of gasoline as a byproduct.
Since combustion engines hadn't been invented,
Doc and Marty would have all the fuel they
needed - for next to nothing.
The Empire Strikes Back
Once the opening battle on Hoth ends, the
Star Wars heroes head their separate ways:
Han and Leia head to Cloud City, while Luke
sets out to find Yoda, and begin his Jedi
training.
The movie cuts back and forth, with Lando
welcoming his friends, only to betray them
to Vader immediately - and Luke undergoing
what seems to be weeks, or months of training
until he senses his friends in danger.
The timelines don't add up, and fans have
crafted some wild ways to explain the difference.
Either it's a plot hole, or becoming a Jedi
was a lot easier than we thought.
Those are the clumsy, unnecessary, or unexplainable
plot holes we found in some of our favorite
movies, but which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments and remember to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.